Kuei, bienvenue à Espaces autochtones,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question d'Anthony
qui me demande « Comment les politiciens
agissent avec vous
depuis la création d'Idle No More? »
Anthony, c'est une bonne question parce que ça
a eu beaucoup de répercussions, le mouvement.
Mais ce n'était pas le premier mouvement
autochtone. Il y a quand même eu d'autres
mouvances des Premières Nations
qui existaient avant l'arrivée d'Idle No More.
Une des mouvances qu'on voit beaucoup en action,
c'est celle de l'APNQL au Québec.
C'est l'Assemblée des Premières
Nations du Québec et du Labrador.
Ça, c'est l'assemblée des chefs
qui se réunissent et qui, par ce canal,
peuvent parler justement avec
les politiciens, que ce soit au niveau
fédéral ou provincial.
Quand on pense à Idle No More,
c'est quand même depuis 2012.
Le changement de ton a quand même été très grand.
Il ne faut pas oublier qu'en 2012,
les mobilisateurs d'Idle No More,
on était sous surveillance des services
de l'intelligence canadienne, donc c'est un peu
les espions du Canada qui nous surveillaient.
Mais, l'année dernière, on a été nommés
dans un top 10 des Premières Nations
à surveiller justement comme étant
des exemples de citoyens.
Pourquoi? C'est parce qu'il y a six ans,
personne ne savait presque rien
sur les communautés. Personne ne savait rien
sur nos moyens de mobilisation,
sur nos mobilisateurs. On connaissait
les personnes avec qui on parlait habituellement,
c'est à dire l'APN, l'APNQL,
mais les gens à l'arrière étaient moins
connus. Ce n'est pas la faute de l'APN et de l'APNQL,
c'était quand même la faute
de ne pas avoir eu d'intérêt par rapport
à ce qui se passait dans les communautés.
Alors en six ans, ce qui a changé,
c'est que les gens ont commencé à dire
« Oh, faudrait peut-être qu'on porte attention! » ,
et les politiciens en premier.
Parce qu'il y a des enjeux qui se passent
sur les communautés, mais les enjeux
des Premières Nations touchent aussi les milieux
urbains, et les milieux urbains,
ce ne sont pas des réserves.
Ce sont des centres qu'on partage
et les enjeux des Premières Nations vont venir
couler dans dans la rivière
qui est non autochtone.
Et là les politiciens, il y a une manière
de le faire qui aurait pu être négative
et il y a une manière de travailler qui peut être positive.
Donc, c'est certain
qu'ils ne veulent pas retomber
dans la même erreur qu'avant 2012 et créer
le même genre de discrimination
ou de rapport de force qui existait
et qui ne doit plus perpétuer. On voit des
commissions, présentement, qui existent,
que ce soit la commission pour les femmes assassinées et disparues ou la commission Viens
sur les relations avec les services publics.
Les commissions,
malheureusement, il en faut parce qu'il faut
réparer l'erreur d'oubli qui a été si long.
Donc, je dirais
que la relation avec
les politiciens a beaucoup changé.
C'est certain qu'on n'est pas encore
des nations qui vont être impliquées
dans la politique non autochtone, mais on est
extrêmement impliquées dans la politique
autochtone. C'est certain que
la porte est ouverte par exemple
pour beaucoup plus de discussions
et de plus en plus de personnes
des Premières Nations vont se présenter
dans les milieux politiques.
Mais c'est vraiment une nouvelle
relation et je pense qu'au Québec,
on a la chance de dire qu'elle est beaucoup
plus positive qu'elle peut l'être des fois
dans d'autres provinces du Canada.
Alors j'espère qu'elle va continuer
à s'améliorer. J'espère que j'ai pu
répondre à ta question, Anthony,
et j'espère surtout que vous n'allez pas hésiter
à partager cette vidéo et à nous envoyer
vos questions à Parole autochtone.
Je vous souhaite
une belle semaine.